Another thing that Dr. Bright is not allowed
to do at the SCP Foundation: Make up jodies
for Morning Calisthenics, including, of course,
the Mickey Mouse Club House song.
In Military parlance, jodies are a name for
the chants performed while marching to keep
the soldiers in time and boost morale.
These can be extremely helpful for military
marches, but not for the group calisthenics
being performed in the Foundation gym.
Certain employees, who chose to remain anonymous
in their HR Reports, described this as “annoying”
and “distracting”, especially when Dr.
Bright chose to sing the Mickey Mouse Club
House song.
Dr. Clef, who did not wish to remain anonymous,
said, “If I have to hear that stupid song
one more time when I’m trying to get my
morning reps in, I’m shoving that goofy
medallion where the sun don’t shine.”
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: Dr. Bright is not
allowed to interact with Dr. Clef without
the presence of a responsible administrator.
After an ordinary lunch meeting between the
two Doctors resulted in a dozen casualties,
several containment breaches, and a glob of
mashed potatoes stuck to the ceiling that
won’t budge no matter how hard the cleaning
staff scrubs, it was decided that the two
should not be in the same room without adequate
supervision.
There have been some follow-up questions (mainly
from Bright and Clef) about who counts as
adequate supervision, so let’s clarify:
Dr. Kondraki does not count.
Agent Strelnikov does not count.
Dr. Mann does not count.
So far, no one counts.
As soon as someone does count?
Trust us, you’ll know.
Don’t call us, we’ll call you.
A Friendly Reminder to All Foundation Staff
- Dr. Bright is NOT: A superhero of any sort,
Head of Public Relations, in charge of Orientation
for new staff, a doctor of psychology, a member
of Site Command, made out of bacon, in possession
of an IQ over 300, Head of SCP Review, or
a member of Maintenance Staff - Sorry boys,
Dr. Bright IS a member of Site Command.
It's usually best not to ask why.
It's O5 Command you're thinking of.
Given that he’s constantly taking other
people’s bodies to propagate himself, it’s
no surprise that Dr. Bright might be a little
prone to the occasional identity crisis.
This is, however, no excuse for him to confuse
others - though especially new recruits - by
claiming to have seemingly every title under
the sun except his own.
Possessing the body of a doctor of psychology
does not mean the title passes to you, Dr.
Bright.
This isn’t Highlander.
Another Thing That Dr. Bright Is Not Allowed
to do At the SCP Foundation: Dr. Bright is
not allowed anywhere near a Renaissance Festival,
especially not with D-class in garb.
The SCP Foundation has some of the most high-tech
equipment you’ve ever seen - Or rather,
never seen.
After all, they’re working with unimaginable
supernatural power, and they need the very
cutting edge in technology to keep all these
anomalous powers contained.
But of course, this can make Foundation employees
long for a simpler time.
However, that’s no excuse for Dr. Bright
to lead a band of D-Classes in medieval garb
- Many of which, by the way, are convicted
killers - to a local Ren Faire.
This has, on multiple occasions, led to fires,
assaults, property damage, and death - Some
of which came from curious Ren Faire attendants
touching Dr. Bright’s medallion to see if
it was real.
Naturally, the Foundation isn’t eager to
see this kind of history repeat itself.
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: Dr. Bright is not
allowed to bargain with personnel for their
"souls."
Not even if he can get them a good deal.
Dr. Bright is believed to have a longstanding
relationship with SCP-1879, the Indoor Salesman,
and while you didn’t hear this from us,
rumor has it that the salesman has promised
Dr. Bright an extremely rare Pokemon card
if he can give him ten human souls.
And Dr. Bright really, really wants that Pokemon
card.
The O5 Council officially decries this action
and requests that any attempts at soul-bartering
perpetrated by Dr. Bright be reported to them
immediately.
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: He is not allowed
to make himself the King of anywhere.
Or Queen!
Thanks to his SCP-963 necklace, Dr. Bright
can steal the bodies of pretty much any non-anomalous
being - including powerful heads of states
and monarchs.
This would definitely be a sweet gig for Dr.
Bright, who could kick back and enjoy all
the benefits of royalty.
The problem is, the Foundation needs him to
work for them, and if ever the necklace is
removed from the ruler, they’ll just drop
dead.
So it’s best to keep Dr. Bright away from
anyone in a position of power when he’s
in one of his more capricious moods.
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: Dr. Bright must be
reminded that the Better Business Bureau is
not the correct agency for dealing with containment
failures from horrible eldritch artifacts
sold by Marshall, Carter, and Dark.
Marshall, Carter, and Dark exist at the frightening
intersection of dark, anomalous power and
unfettered capitalism.
They’re one of the most powerful groups
of interest out there, with almost unlimited
funds and an utterly ruthless desire to profit
at all costs.
The Better Business Bureau are utterly toothless
against a group of their sheer, unrelenting
power.
They can grease any palm and snap any neck.
The poor, lowly BBB would not be able to land
a hit on them.
The IRS, on the other hand, is a completely
different story…
Another Thing Dr. Bright Is Not Allowed To
Do At The SCP Foundation: Challenge anyone
to a duel and then give them SCP-572.
Challenging other Foundation personnel to
a duel is a terrible idea at the best of times
- That’s how we lost Dr. Hamilton - but
it becomes especially farcical with SCP-572.
572 is a shoddy and poorly weighted katana
that, to anyone using it, appears to be a
blade of awesome power, that drives them to
perform ill-considered and dangerous stunts.
These often result in the injury of themselves
or others until the sword is taken from them,
or they’re knocked out.
It causes major headaches for the Foundation
whenever it’s used, but of course, Dr. Bright
thinks it’s hi-larious.
Another Thing That Doctor Bright is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: He’s no longer
allowed to challenge Able to unwinnable games
like tic-tac-toe.
It was three weeks before Able conceded a
draw.
It probably shouldn’t surprise you that
Able, legendary swordsman and component of
SCP-076, both takes himself very seriously
and has a bit of a competitive streak.
That’s why Dr. Bright enjoys getting under
his skin by challenging him to pointless and
unwinnable games like tic-tac-toe, just to
watch him get steamed.
The problem is, when Able gets steamed, there
tends to be a large amount of collateral damage.
That’s why, during containment breaches.
Dr. Bright is advised to keep himself and
his snakes and ladders board well away from
the affected area.
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: Attempting to disprove
343, to 343.
It’s a horrible idea.
Agents are still studying the resulting paperweight,
supposedly so heavy that 343 should not be
able to lift it.
For context, while debate around the truth
of this matter rages among Foundation staff
and in our comment sections, SCP-343 is a
reality-warping anomaly that refers to itself
as God - believed to be omnipresent, omniscient,
and omnipotent.
A classic thought experiment on the possibility
of this is whether God is capable of creating
an object they themself couldn’t lift - resulting
in a paradox.
Or, in this case, an astronomically heavy
paperweight that the SCP Foundation now needs
to deal with.
Thanks, Jack.
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: No ending reports
with lyrics from "The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air".
Sometimes work at the SCP Foundation can get
a bit grueling, so Dr. Bright tries to “brighten”
everyone’s day with a little pop culture
reference or two.
However, after a report on SCP-096’s potential
origins concluded with “In West of the Arctic,
born and raised, in the mountains is where
he spent most of his days.”
His colleagues agreed that enough was enough.
However, after he submitted a formal request,
he was given certain allowances.
Mainly, he can use lyrics from Safety Dance,
as the majority of the research staff still
find them funny.
Most notably, he ended a report on SCP-049
with: “You can cure if you want to, you
can leave your friends behind.
Cause your friends got plague and if they’ve
got plague then they’re no friends of mine!”
After his accompanying dance nearly broke
a window and triggered a containment breach
of SCP-173, however, his boogying privileges
were revoked.
Another Thing Doctor Bright is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation:
Dr. Bright is not allowed to feed anything
with peanut butter to Kain.
And no, we don’t mean SCP-073, that’s
Cain with a C.
This is Dr. Kain Pathos Crow, a legendary
SCP Foundation researcher who, through some
anomalous accident, got turned into a dog
with human-level intelligence and ability.
Dr. Bright is no stranger to being an animal
thanks to his body-swapping necklace, so he
may want to treat his colleague to a nice
spoonful of peanut butter as an act of solidarity
- After all, peanut butter without xylitol
is safe for dogs to eat.
But no matter how funny Dr. Bright thinks
it is, the O5 Council is not amused by the
constant sounds of Dr. Crow trying to lick
peanut butter off the roof of his mouth during
staff meetings.
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: No handing out instances
of SCP-437 as weaponry to unsuspecting new
researchers.
Dr. Bright has a real taste for Mischief,
bloodshed, and root beer floats, or, as he
calls them, the three major food groups.
New researchers at the Foundation, with their
difficulty recognizing sarcasm, often find
themselves in the crosshairs of his goofier
moods.
Well one of his cruelest jokes of all time,
however, is introducing new researchers to
SCP-437 without any kind of warning.
Imagine starting a new job, and meeting someone
of a higher rank than you that you think you
can trust.
This person tells you to check out a specialized
weapon, and when you do, you find trees that
have disturbingly human faces in their bark,
sap made from blood, and the muffled sound
of agonized screaming emanating from within.
Dr. Bright has been formally censured for
this behavior, and warned that if it continues,
he will be responsible for covering all resulting
therapy bills.
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: No leading a Mobile
Task Force against the UIU under any circumstances!
The Unusual Incidents Unit of the FBI is a
generally well-meaning, but often irritating
presence in the world of anomalous research.
It’s the annoying little brother who insists
on following you and your friends around when
you’re trying to play big boy games, for
crying out loud!
But that doesn’t mean that it’s acceptable
to lead a Mobile Task Force against them.
With Bright’s newly formed task force, he
approached a UIU building and proceeded to
order a series of “ding dong ditches,”
wherein task force members would ring the
doorbell and then run away laughing before
anyone could catch them.
They also covered the exterior of the building
in eggs, toilet paper, and a substance later
revealed to be a lightly radioactive form
of silly string.
Though no real damage was done, this behavior
was described by the O5 Council as “just
kind of mean?”
Dr. Bright has been prohibited from leading
any more Task Forces in the future.
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: He should not replace
the buckshot in Dr. Clef's shotgun shells
with any of the following: birdseed, confetti,
cake sprinkles, sawdust, or glitter.
Being a loose-cannon, ex-GOC operative, it
goes without saying that Dr. Clef loves his
shotgun, and during containment breaches,
he’s the first to charge in with said shotgun
and face down his anomalous enemies.
However, as funny as Dr. Bright thinks it
may be, he really shouldn’t replace Dr.
Clef’s buckshot with any number of amusing,
harmless alternatives.
While seeing SCP-682 get a face full of cake
sprinkles certainly is something, if Dr. Clef
needs to spend another week in traction as
a result of it, he’s going to have some
serious words for Dr. Bright.
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: No sending Nigerian
Prince-esque spam emails to the Church of
the Broken God!
Email is a vital communication tool to keep
any workplace running smoothly, even the SCP
Foundation!
However, like any great tool, it can also
be used for evil.
Or just a bit of chaos.
Dr. Bright decided to play a prank, and earn
a bit of extra cash, by posing as a sentient
machine in need of help from the Church of
the Broken God.
“Pls respond…need 100,000 US Dollars to
fight against the Sarkites…for the glory
of Mekhane…send ur routing number and bank
information ASAP.”
The Church quickly wired the money, and were
enraged when they learned they had been duped.
They retaliated by leaving flaming bags of
dog poop on the front steps of several Foundation
Sites.
Needless to say, Dr. Bright has been encouraged
to find another outlet for his more mischievous
impulses.
They did keep the money though.
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: Dr. Bright must be
informed that SCP-018 is not to be taunted!
SCP-018 is also known as the Super Ball, and
it’s a small rubber ball created by the
Wham-O corporation, with the frightening and
destructive ability to bounce higher and faster
every single time it bounces, resulting in
rampant chaos.
So naturally, Dr. Bright has, on occasion,
gotten it out of containment to try bouncing
it around, likely destroying large amounts
of Foundation office equipment and terrorizing
all nearby staff members.
As such, his privileges around the Super Ball
have been revoked, and the O5 Council has
advised that Dr. Bright sticks to a simple,
non-anomalous paddle ball instead.
Another Thing Dr. Bright Is Not Allowed To
Do at the SCP Foundation: If a mind-controlling
SCP is discovered, it is to be turned over
to the proper authorities.
It is not to be used to advance himself or
others higher in the Foundation.
Look, we’ve all wanted to be more persuasive
people.
Maybe it’s about getting a new job, or a
raise, or convincing your buddies to see the
movie you want to see at the theater, rather
than the Steven Segal movies they always insist
on.
But Dr. Bright using mind-controlling SCPs
to help advance himself at the Foundation,
or making Dr. Kondraki pee his pants so that
he can take his projects while Kondraki is
put on mandatory mental health leave, is simply
not acceptable professional conduct.
Isn’t Dr. Bright anomalously powerful enough
already?
We really don’t need him gaining the power
to control the human mind.
It just won’t end well.
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: Don't let Dr. Bright
get a sample of SCP-379.
Let my laptop be the last victim.
SCP-379 is a clear liquid nicknamed the Mechanical
Pheremone.
Once applied, any machines in its proximity
will begin to act as though they’re sentient,
infatuated beings, including overheating,
slower response time, a preference in contact
with the wearer, and a higher rate of glitches.
Dr. Bright may think it’s funny to spritz
a little SCP-379 and take a walk through one
of Site-19’s IT wings, but Technical Director
Rosen ardently disagrees.
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: SCP-963 is not to
be used for recreational or procreational
purposes.
Well, uh, this one leaves a frightening amount
open to interpretation.
SCP-963 is Dr. Bright’s medallion which
houses his consciousness and can pass it on
to others.
If ever it remains connected to one body for
over thirty days, it leaves a permanent copy
inside the body, meaning Dr. Bright could
theoretically make clones of himself.
He’s generally not allowed to do the latter
under any circumstances, but especially if
the plan is to, say, use the copy to do menial
chores or stand in for him at more boring
meetings while Dr. Bright plays solitaire
in his office.
And they definitely wouldn’t tolerate Dr.
Bright committing any…
Um…
Onanism…
With his clones, thank you very much.
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: No using SCPs to
create tentacle monsters - even if Dr. Palmer
asks nicely!
There are a vast number of anomalous technologies
that would allow a bored Dr. Bright to try
his hand at playing god with some genetic
engineering - Including, in theory, creating
tentacle monsters.
This may seem innocent enough, but due to
certain Japanese censorship laws, tentacle
monsters have taken on a whole new meaning.
Especially to one of Dr. Bright’s colleagues,
Dr. Palmer, who’ll happily tell you about
her favorite anime: “My Husband is a Tentacle
Monster In Another World.”
Needless to say, the Foundation would prefer
that their employees do this kind of thing
at home.
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: Dr. Bright may not
use any form of the word 'accident' as an
excuse.
We get it, Dr. Bright, real accidents do happen.
Nobody is perfect, least of all, you.
But considering some of the complexity of
the antics you’ve been up to lately, we
find it extremely hard to believe that you
did it all by accident.
Did you accidentally slip and program “Dr.
Clef’s Pee” into SCP-294, and then pour
it into Dr. Kondraki’s briefcase, so that
the two would fight each other?
You’re really beginning to stretch the suspension
of disbelief here…
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: Dr. Bright should
be reminded that victims of SCP-217 are not
toys, nor are they to be used as props at
a Steampunk Convention.
SCP-217, also known as the Clockwork Virus,
is a terrifying anomalous pathogen that slowly
converts the organic material of its victims
into analog mechanized elements, eventually
leaving them looking like inoperative steampunk
nightmares.
Of course, Dr. Bright has no permanent body,
and thus, it wouldn’t really hold much of
a threat for him.
Therefore, he could, in theory, start treating
the infected individuals like big, strange
robotic toys, but for the sake of human decency,
the O5 Council would really, really, really
prefer that he didn’t.
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: Dr. Bright is not
allowed to violate the SCP Foundation dress
code, nor encourage others to do so, even
on “Casual Fridays.”
A note appended to this rule reads, “No
matter how many times you say please, Dr.
Bright, we won't put any of the hats you've
been asking about into the dress code.”
And the list of hats that Dr. Bright has facetiously
requested has been nothing short of impressive,
including a freakishly tall, white “Doug
Dimmadome”-esque cowboy hat, and a novelty
propellor hat with actual, functioning helicopter
propellors.
A number of other hats he’s suggested - simple,
non-anomalous baseball caps with humorous
slogans printed on them - have been deemed
to be HR violations.
Sorry, Jack.
Another Thing That Dr. Bright Isn’t Allowed
To Do At The SCP Foundation: Pretend that
SCP-963 is a joy buzzer!
For those who aren’t in the know, SCP-963
is the medallion that you’ll always find
on Dr. Bright’s person - It’s an indestructible
vector for his essence, his very soul.
Anyone who touches it suffers immediate brain
death, and Dr. Bright’s consciousness is
transferred to their body.
So, naturally, when Dr. Bright is feeling
mischievous, it’s not a very responsible
prank to treat SCP-963 like a joy buzzer - Considering
it will kill its victims instantly.
It’s like making a whoopee cushion filled
with nerve gas or a fake stick of gum that’s
actually plastic explosives.
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: no using SCPs to
affect the outcome on American Idol, or any
other reality show competition!
Previous violations of this rule have included:
showing his least favorite American Idol contestant
SCP-096’s face in the hope that it would
hunt him down, sneaking SCP-348 to a Hell’s
Kitchen contestant, and releasing SCP-049
into the house on The Bachelorette because,
quote, “None of them are good enough for
Rachel, so they all deserve to die.”
Dr. Bright is to be reminded that, if he cannot
stay on his best behavior and stay out of
the competition, his tv privileges will be
revoked.
And does he really want to risk missing the
latest season of Love is Blind?
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: Dr. Bright is not
allowed to edit the list of things he is not
allowed to do!
Due to some unsubstantiated rumors perpetuated
by Dr. Bright himself, we must issue a formal
correction.
If an SCP file says never to do something,
that is not because we are trying to control
your mind.
For example, warnings not to look at SCP-096’s
face are for your own protection.
If you would like to look at its face and
bring about your own untimely end, then that
is up to you, but don’t say we didn’t
warn you.
AHEM!
No, we are not.
Dr. Bright, I see you.
You can’t type into this script any more,
your IP address has already been blocked!
In conclusion, if he would let us get our
work done for once in his miserable endless
life, Dr. Bright is not allowed to attempt
any manipulation, mind control, or subterfuge
of any kind via official SCP Foundation documents.
Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: Telling new researchers
that you can tame SCP-682 with a rolled-up
newspaper and a tummy rub.
When you’ve been alive for as long as Dr.
Bright, with the knowledge of eternity stretching
out before you, you can watch every movie
and show, play every game, and read every
book.
That’s why Dr. Bright sometimes resorts
to more esoteric methods of amusement.
Such as feeding the newbies little white lies
about anomalies, like telling them SCP-682
can be tamed with a rolled-up newspaper and
tummy rubs, like a misbehaving puppy.
Which must have seemed really funny until
six new researchers got devoured.
And considering what a nightmare employee
turnaround is at the SCP Foundation already,
losing employees for a reason this stupid
really didn’t sit well with the O5 Council…